when most people think of Batman's
nemesis they tend to think of the Joker
but lately it sounds like the Caped
Crusader's arch enemy is a PC my name is
Jake and here's why you might want to
hold off on buying Telltale's latest
adventure like Batman Arkham Knight
Batman the tell-tale series is
experiencing numerous issues if you've
been perusing user reviews on Steam
you've probably noticed a common theme
the game is suffering from frequent
crashes low frame rates resolution
problems and gamepad issues if you are
experiencing these issues you may need
to update your graphics card drivers but
that still may not fix it however it
seems these problems aren't happening to
everyone our reviewer had a relatively
problem-free experience as well as some
other people in our office but the game
crash for me six times during my first
playthrough and once during our live
stream as of now telltale has not issued
a statement but I'd be willing to bet
that a patch is on the way if you can't
wait that long to toad spandex and a
gravelly voice it may be worth getting
on ps4 or Xbox one if you have that
option for more on Batman and a ton of
gaming news keep those pointy ears
directed to GameSpot